There are many different misconceptions in
life.
Many.
And one of the things misconceptions tend
to do is they tend to prevent people from
doing things that could benefit them.
They say things like, "Oh my God, I don't
know if I want to do this" because in their
mind, this is what they believe, so they don't
do it.
So the definition of a misconception, the
meaning of misconception is a thought or an
opinion that is incorrect because it is based
on faulty thinking or understanding.
So today, I want to clarify some of the misconceptions
of entrepreneurship.
I'm right now at College Station, Texas, which
is the home of the Aggies, Texas A&M University.
These guys invited me to come and speak to
their next class of entrepreneurs.
They have a program here called Entrepreneurship
Society.
And last time when I was talking to these
young, aspiring entrepreneurs, they had so
many different misconceptions.
I have nine of them I want to share with you.
So the first one is this.
Here's one of the biggest misconceptions that
I keep hearing about.
Entrepreneurs are born.
Constantly.
You are born an entrepreneur, which is an
absolute lie, if there ever was one.
Yes, it's like saying one is born with a forty
inch vertical leap.
Yes, you're right.
Larry Bird did not have a 40-inch vertical
leap, so he cannot dunk like LeBron James.
Yes.
But that doesn't mean you are born to be a
basketball player, and Larry Bird is not.
That has no meaning.
Michael Jordan was born to be a basketball
player.
But Steph Curry was not, because he's 6'1"
170 pounds.
You can't say that because he's a tiny guy.
Muggys Bogues was a 5' 3" basketball player.
5' 3" and he played the NBA, nearly ten something
years, and he was pretty good at it.
So the same goes to saying this person is
not meant to be an entrepreneur because he's
too shy.
This person's not meant to be an entrepreneur
because he had a 1.8 GPA in high school.
because he's a certain nationality or color
of skin.
No.
Don't buy it.
It's misconceptions.
Someone's trying to persuade you, that you
can't become an entrepreneur and it's not
the truth.
It's faulty thinking, and you need to question
it.
You don't need to just say, "Oh, this guy
on YouTube said that entrepreneurs are born."
BS.
Don't buy it.
It's a misconception.
#2: The second thing is something I struggled
with is, you have to cheat or steal, to win
as an entrepreneur.
You do not.
You do not have to cheat or steal as an entrepreneur.
I've watched this for many, many years with
my business.
I had to compete and some people did it the
right way, some people did it the wrong way.
Some people had shortcuts and every single
time there's a shortcut, we're tempted.
Everybody's tempted.
I was tempted.
Every time, I'm sitting here competing against
a guy that's making 400 grand a month, and
I'm only making 30 grand a month, and I'm
25 years old, whatever it is, 26 years old.
And he's doing certain things that I don't
want to do.
But if I have to compete with him, I have
to do that to compete with him.
I didn't do it, he kept doing it.
He lost his licenses.
We kept going.
Now if I would have done it, I would have
also lost my license.
You do not have to cheat or steal to win in
business.
You don't.
You do not have to cheat or steal to win in
business.
People say that, because it is a way out for
them to say, I chose not to be an entrepreneur
because I am a noble human being.
And because I'm a noble human being, I refuse
to cheat, because it's against my character.
That is not true.
You don't have to cheat or steal to become
an entrepreneur.
There are laws, you break them, you're going
straight to prison.
#3: They got lucky.
This whole lucky thing.
And by the way, I talk about lucky quite a
lot.
On one end, luck doesn't happen accidentally.
For example, nobody is going to go on a date
with a beautiful girl by not talking to her.
You have to take action.
There's got to be a conversation.
No one closes a big sale, without knowing
anything about their products, because the
bigger the sale it is, the more educated the
customer is.
You can't just go to a customer and ask for
a $200,000 check and they're going to say
yes and you know nothing about your product.
It's not going to happen.
You have to work your butt off to become an
expert.
You have to immerse yourself on it.
You're going to go through certain breaking
points that you don't feel like doing anything,
and you want to throw in the towel.
Those moments are things that people don't
see.
Nobody sees I'm in Hilton right now.
And I remember one time we were on the tour
last year when we were doing the entrepreneurship
tour.
We stopped by Conrad Hilton where he accidentally
bought this building, it was a hospital?
It was something.
It wasn't a hotel, right?
He bought this thing, he turned it into a
hotel.
Next thing you know, it started growing.
There's Hiltons in Iran.
And I'm in Iran, I've gone to a Hilton when
I was a kid growing up, Hilton was like insane.
We don't know the stories of when Hilton almost
went out of business.
We don't know the stories of his arguments
with his wife.
We don't know the times where he's at a hotel
room by himself away from a kid's birthday
because he has to be at a business meeting,
and he's absolutely feeling crap about the
fact that he missed an event for his kid or
. . you don't know those moments.
So you can't say they got lucky.
There is luck involved in business.
I'm not telling you there isn't.
Nothing wrong with getting lucky.
But there's got to be a lot of hard work before
you get lucky.
#4: Selfish.
Entrepreneurs are selfish.
You'll hear the word selfish, greedy, and
all they care about is money, quite regularly.
They're selfish.
They're very selfish.
They're all selfish.
All they care about is themselves.
Listen.
You can't build a billion dollar company - when
you build a billion dollar company, the guy
that built a billion dollar company, he doesn't
keep the billion dollars.
The billion dollar company, he probably keeps
a fifty million dollar salary per year, let's
just say if you build a billion dollar company.
Now if you own a big part of it, sure.
The value of the company is yours.
But if your company grows to a billion dollars
per year, he takes $50 million a year income.
Even people say that's greedy.
Let's say he takes a $50 million a year income,
because I'm picking a the greediest CEO you
can think about.
He's taking a $50 million a year income, he
built a billion dollar company, okay?
Where does that $950 million go to?
You tell me.
Does that go in his pocket?
No.
It goes to what?
It goes to employees, it goes to healthcare.
It goes to building.
It goes to a lease.
It goes to construction.
It goes to long communication, Internet, servers.
These are all jobs being created.
A billion dollar empire is creating $950 million
dollars of revenue to other people that lead
to taxes.
You can't be selfish and build a big company.
You just cannot.
You can be selfish and be a salesperson, because
all you're doing is selling and it's all you,
one person show, one-man show, because it's
all about you.
Yes, you can be selfish.
I agree with you.
It's impossible for you to build an empire
being selfish.
It's mathematically impossible for you to
build a big empire being selfish.
The math doesn't make sense.
You can't win an NBA championship without
having assist.
You can't.
It's never happened, and it's never going
to happen.
You can't win a baseball game without having
somebody that's double playing the team, catches
the ball.
You can't have it.
You can't have a no hit.
I can go on with any different sport.
You cannot do it without having a team that's
selfish.
It just does not work.
It is not going to work that way.
Not in the world of business.
#5: All you need is a great idea and product.
A lot of people message me and say, "Pat,
guess what, man."
What's that?
"Man, I've got this product, you and I need
to team up.
It's a billion dollar idea.
I promise you, bro.
You're going to be a billionaire.
You can do this."
I'm like, you really think ideas are what
makes a billion dollar.
. you think the idea is what makes it a billion
dollars?
Really?
You think an idea is?
An idea means nothing.
Nothing.
You know why?
Because very few execute.
Very few execute.
And here's another thing about ideas.
There are many crappy products in the world
that are sold on the shelves of Wal-Mart.
Many.
There are many crappy products in the world
that are sold at Macy's and people buy.
And their products suck.
There are many shirts that you go buy, where
the strings are out with the shirt.
It's just terrible.
People buy them.
Why do they buy?
So your idea that you have, means nothing
if there's no execution.
An idea's just an idea.
There are many great ideas out there.
Execution is the issue.
#6: All you need is to raise capital.
People say, Pat, if I raise money, man - like
last time one kid was asking me, "I'm telling
you, if I had a million dollars right now,
I'd do this."
If I heard, every single time somebody told
me "if I had a million dollar investment,"
I'd be a billionaire today.
Everybody wants to talk about if they had
money and raised capital.
It means nothing.
It does mean a little bit.
Don't get me wrong.
But you're not going to get a - I get messages,
"Pat, can you do a video on how to raise capital?"
I'll do a video on how to raise capital.
Can you do a video on how to raise capital?
I will.
I'll definitely do that.
"Because if I have the capital, I'll do this,
this, this with my business."
And I'll tell them.
I'll say, have you ever wanted a pass before?
Who are you?
How hard do you work?
What's your track record?
What relationships do you have?
What associations do you have?
Who needs to bet on you?
Would you bet on you?
Why should someone bet on you?
If you can answer those questions, you'll
eventually raise capital.
If you don't have that, you ain't getting
capital.
It's that simple.
Your reputation and track record and the relationships
and the associations who validate you, will
attract the capital.
If you don't have this, there is no capital.
It's simple.
You have to have a lot of this on the front
end, to get the money.
#7: They all had great initial connections,
because it's all about the contacts and connections.
My connections were guys who went to the nightclub
on a weekly basis.
My connections were guys who were chasing
skirts.
My connections were my boys and we'd sit down
and talk sports all day long and you know,
play spades or play whatever cards, play all
these other games.
That's my connections.
So who are my connections?
I didn't go to university to be part of an
alumni.
What are my connections?
My connections from the military never ever
introduced me to anybody in business.
These are my connections from military.
They don't have a business background.
Who are my connections?
Connections are a by-product of a lot of work,
of people seeing you saying, "This guy's legit.
He's working hard.
Let's connect him to this person."
It's not, Hey, this person had a father who's
related to Vanderbilt and.
. . no.
It does not work that way.
If you have that, it's an edge.
I had zero.
My parents have never been entrepreneurs.
I don't come from a business background.
My dad stopped going to school after 8th grade
to help support his family.
I'm not the smart kid on campus.
Nothing.
None of that stuff.
I had to work my tail off to get my connections.
If you're looking for shortcuts, misconception.
#8: It's a massive risk.
I've got to take such a massive risk.
This is why I don't want to become an entrepreneur.
I've seen so many people lose everything and
all this other stuff.
Yes.
There are a lot of people that lose everything.
You're right.
There are a lot of people that go all in.
And we always want to watch on YouTube guys
who go all in, who what?
Who win.
Oh, this guy went all in.
What a smart guy, man.
He went all in and he won.
Now that guy's a great poker player."
Okay, there's a little luck there, right?
But you don't have to go all in every single
time.
Many people can start a business part time
while you have a job and you just start testing
your product and see how people are responding
to it.
Anybody can start a business part-time and
work through it.
You don't have to start full-time.
When Apple got started, when I interviewed
Steve Wozniak, we can put a clip of it.
But when I interviewed Steve Wozniak, they
started their business while he had a full-time
job, and Steve had a full-time job, and they
started messing around with this thing out
of their garage and then it grew and they
said, "Let's quit our jobs."
And Wozniak didn't want to quit his job for
a few months.
But they finally did.
They started part-time and they tested it.
You can, too.
#9: Last one is entrepreneurs are their own
boss.
Everybody says, "You become an entrepreneur,
you're your own boss."
That is the misconception.
You are not your own boss.
Like when people say, "When you have kids,
you're the man of the household."
Really?
Your kids tell you what to do.
You have to drop them off at school.
You have to pick them up in the morning.
You get a lot more sleep if you don't have
kids.
They wake you up three, four times in the
middle of the night.
My daughter right now is waking us up in the
middle of the night two or three times.
They're the boss.
I'm not the boss.
I happen to support and fund their life, but
they're my boss.
So as an entrepreneur, my customers are my
boss.
I have tens of thousands of customers that
are my boss.
I have thousands of sales people that are
my boss.
I have employees that are my boss.
I have vendors.
I have partners.
I have relationships, I have the media.
These are people that you yourself had to
learn how to support and the more, the better
you improve and the more you grow your business,
then the more leverage and influence and trust
you have, it's easier to move your business.
But you are not your own boss when it comes
down to running everything 100% of the time.
That is a misconception of entrepreneurship.
So look.
I can go on and talk about many, many more
things, when it comes down to misconceptions.
My challenge to you is, don't let these nine
misconceptions prevent you from becoming an
entrepreneur.
Share this video with somebody else that maybe
is on the verge of saying, "I don't want to
be an entrepreneur."
Or if they've said any of these nine things,
have them watch this video.
And have them think about it from a completely
different perspective.
Because unfortunately, unfortunately, unfortunately,
many of these same misconceptions prevent
people from living their dream life.
Some kid asked me yesterday, he said, hey,
how's it feel now, having the life that you
have?"
And I told him, I said, "I was this close
of just being a regular guy, making 52 grand
a year.
This close.
I was this close.
Regular guy.
Regular guy, nothing is growing, nothing is
expanding.
I was this close.
I almost bought into this misconception.
I almost did.
I almost was convinced by my family, friends,
and many other media and associations that
I had.
but I didn't do it.
And I want to challenge you to do the same
as well.
Now, we have a problem that I need your help
with.
We're in Texas right now, without our favorite
pillow, we left behind.
But this is what we want to do with our pillow.
And I'm putting the challenge out there to
everybody, who is a big Valuetainment fan.
This is what we're doing.
I am looking for a new pillow for 2017.
A new subscribe pillow for 2017.
So I want you to, I'm going to give credit
to the pillow that we use.
I want you to either find a nice pillow for
Valuetainment that you can customize with
the Valuetainment logo on it and the YouTube
logo on it, whatever it is, big or small.
I don't care what it is.
It's got to be a good one that I hold.
And it will be yours, for the rest of 2017
I will hold that pillow.
So, you can make it.
Custom make it.
Have somebody make it.
I don't care what it is.
You can buy one at the store that's six, seven
bucks, that you like it, and you want to send
it to us.
Anything you find.
I want you to send us all the pillows.
Here's the address you can send it to 5001
Spring Valley Road, Ste.
number 1155 E., that's in Dallas, Texas, 75244.
We'll put the address in the description as
well.
Send your pillows our way.
Make sure it's got subscribe on it.
Make sure it's got Valuetainment - be creative
on whatever way you want to do it.
But I'm definitely looking forward to seeing
some of those pillows being sent over to the
headquarters.
Again, the address will be on the bottom.
And if you haven't subscribed to this channel,
please do so.
If you've got any questions, thoughts about
what I talked about today, post your comments
on the bottom.
Take care everybody, bye bye.